Nintendo switch is a great console name
that implies a lot of things I mean what
the hell does Wii U mean anyway but
outside of one reveal trailer and a few
confirmed details we hardly know
anything about it with a ful
presentation happening this Thursday we
don't have to wait much longer to have
our questions answered so what can we
expect here are four things to keep in
mind number one
the controller the switch is a hybrid
console which means you can take it
outside or plug it into the dock to play
on your big TV at home the gamepad
itself has removable controllers called
joi cons on either side but what about
that screen in the middle reports from
bloggers Emily Rogers and Laura Kate
Dale claim it's a touchscreen given
Nintendo's history with the Wii U 3ds
and original DS touch screen
functionality only makes sense
as for the joi cons themselves
customization is another question
immature user the grumpy cat created
some alternate color schemes for the
system which do fall in line with
Nintendo's various shades of game boys
and DS's artist Ryan Sal Amanda took
this idea even further sketching out a
few possibilities for alternate joi con
shapes and button layouts it's a
brilliant idea that just can't be unseen
but also it's super unconfirmed so don't
get too attached number 2 the specs so
what about the guts of the console
ventureBeat reports that the switch uses
Nvidia's Maxwell graphics processor
rather than the manufacturers newer
Pascal technology
this means the console has just over a
teraflop of performance power making it
less powerful than the baseline ps4 or
Xbox one digital foundry went more in
depth digging into the switches CPU and
GPU speeds according to the site CPU
speeds are constant whether the console
is docked or removed this way the game
runs the same in your living room as it
does on the go the GPU however is down
clock to just 40 percent of its total
power when not plugged in earlier
digital foundry reports claim the
controller sports a 720p screen
so the graphics will stay pretty as they
eat up less GPU power number three the
price so how much are you gonna be
paying for this thing UK retailer games
seek listed the system at around two
hundred pounds or about two hundred and
fifty dollars the same price our friend
Laura Kate Dale stated would be listed
by game another UK store loser rumors
from website mobi Pickers said that
bundles will start at two hundred and
sixty dollars with a 300 dollar Mario
bundle and a three hundred and forty
dollars Zelda and pro controller bundle
also available those prices have not
been confirmed and neither has a new
Mario game for that matter but given
that we use $300 and three hundred and
fifty dollar launch units they don't
seem too outlandish number for the games
perhaps the biggest question of all is
what games the Nintendo switch will
offer Legend of Zelda breath of the wild
has been slated for a while
more recently play tonics ukulele has
been confirmed for the system along with
Dragon Quest 10 Dragon Quest eleven lego
city undercover and rime indie darling
stardew valley also has a switch version
in the works and two more indie games
seasons of heaven and the sacred hero
have also been announced the switches
debut trailer also teased skyrim NBA 2k
17 different versions of Mario Kart 8
and splatoon and what appears to be a
new Mario game but none of these have
been officially announced a third
version of Pokemon Sun and Moon titled
Pokemon stars has also been reported and
on top of all of that
a report from Eurogamer claims the
Virtual Console will be updated to
feature GameCube titles if you're
looking for a reason to visit Super
Mario Sunshine you just might get it the
Nintendo switch presentation kicks off
Thursday January 12th at 8 p.m. Pacific
11 p.m. Eastern Nintendo will be talking
specs price and launch lineup so these
questions should have solid answers will
hopefully get that March release window
narrowed down to keep an eye on GameSpot
for all the new info and look for some
hot new switch gameplay very soon